divise ou indivise telle est la question
une copropriété divise c'est ce qu'on
appelle familièrement un condo chaque
logement appartient entièrement à son
propriétaire en indivise c'est un pour
tous 12 pour un comme des conjoints
propriétaires d'une maison par exemple
les coûts propriétaires indivisent
possèdent donc une part de tous les 10
fils et en principe ils sont
solidairement responsables d'une seule
hypothèque aujourd'hui toutefois
certaines institutions offrent des
hypothèques et responsabilités limitées
où chacun est responsable que de sa
quote-part mais tous demeurent
solidairement responsable des taxes et
des assurances ce qui peut d'ailleurs
être avantageux un compte de taxes
unique est souvent moins élevé que si la
copropriété était divise
autre chose la SCHL elle n'assure pas
les prêts de copropriété indivisent
l'acheteur doit donc donner une mise de
fonds de 20% plutôt que les habituels
5%. dernier détail si la copropriété
indivise que vous convoitez est occupée
par un locataire il pourrait faire
valoir son droit au maintien dans les
lieux ce qui vous empêchera de prendre
possession de votre appartement alors
divise ou indivise une chose est sûre ne
laissez pas cette question sans réponse
passer le mot
[Musique]